ganz kurz zur übersicht für eine
kurzanleitung geben und dann über die
lebensform als form des denkens sprechen
da haben wir glaube ich auch schon ein
unterschiedliches verständnis in töpfe
und ich dass mir geht es hier um das
richtige verständnis des begriffs als
begriff also sehr hygienisch und weniger
um eine typisierung im biologischen
sinne
dann geht es um die naturgemäße
normativität nicht thomaner lebewesen
vor dir ich eintreten möchte und hier
möchte ich eine weitere differenzierung
in zug für hinzufügen wird spricht da
wir schon gehört haben von rachel dohme
titty und insbesondere von natural
goodness im rahmen einer doktorarbeit
fokussiere ich mich stärker auf die
andere seite der naturgemäßen
normativität nämlich die naturgemäße
zuträglich kalt die glaube ich es
besonders wichtig mit blick auf
konsequenzen für eine ethik der belebten
natur und da werde ich zwei konsequenzen
kurz skizzieren die ich meine die sich
aus der naturgemäßen normativität führen
nicht um eine lebewesen ergeben dass
also der fahrplan
wenn auch teilweise deutlich
unterschiedlichen ausprägungen vertreten
aristoteles kant schelling und hegel die
auffassung dass die zweckmäßige
verfasstheit von lebewesen als das
zentrale bestimmung moment der belebten
natur auszumachen ist
für alle genannten autoren zeichnen sich
wesen die als natur zweck existieren
dadurch aus dass sie von sich selbst
zugleich ursache und wirkung sind
beziehungsweise bekannt dass wir eine
dass wir nicht anders als so zu denken
sie vermögen zeitgenössische autoren wie
thompson forsthaus und coast guard
teilen diese auffassung der zweckmäßigen
verfasstheit von lebewesen
sie gehen damit also weiterhin davon aus
dass eine wohlverstandenen theologen
teleologische erklärung erforderlich ist
um die beliebte von der unbelebten natur
abzugrenzen genannte historische wie
zeitgenössische autoren stimmen mithin
überein dass lebewesen im gegensatz zu
dingen nicht bloß durch kausal
mechanische beschreibungen erklärt
werden können ein universal
mechanistische reduktionismus ist vor
diesem hintergrund ebenso zurückzuweisen
wie eine internationale universal
theologie beim menschen dessen
lebensform zusätzlich subjektivität auf
sich vereinigt stimmen natur und
freiheit im sinne von natur theologie
und internationaler theologie also im
sinne von natur zwecksetzung und selbst
zwecksetzung zusammen
das ist ein sehr spezieller und
natürlich der komplexeste und
komplizierteste fall um den wird es im
meinen ausführungen weniger gehen also
ich konzentriere mich wirklich auf die
nicht humane natur die aber natürlich
immer vor dem hintergrund wie er auch
schon gesagt hat der humanen lebensform
normativ überhaupt erst bewertet werden
kann ja in meiner dissertation
lebensform und anerkennungs verhältnis
verbinde ich für eine philosophische
beleuchtung des menschen natur
verhältnisses und den damit
angesprochenen fragestellungen natur
ethische reflexionen mit anerkennungs
theoretischen überlegungen der fokus
richtet sich im folgenden auf die
argumentation für eine naturgemäße
normativität nicht humaner lebewesen als
exemplare einer lebensform und die damit
verbundenen ethischen konsequenzen
die kommen zum zweiten punkt lebensform
als form des denkens teilweise
wiederholen sich die sachen ich habe zum
glück nicht gehört die gleichen
abschnitt wieder töpfer ausgewählt aber
jetzt bei mir gibt's auch erstmal um
thompson
der nämlich anknüpfend an hegel gezeigt
hat das leben eine logische kategorie
repräsentiert und der lebensform begriff
ausschließlich mit begrifflichen und
nicht empirischen differenzierungen
operiert hinsichtlich ihrer logischen
formen sind aussagen über lebewesen und
aussagen über unbeliebtes grundlegend
unterschieden
des weiteren hat thompson dargelegt dass
es kein rein empirisch tisches
verständnis von lebensformen geben kann
wissen über lebensformen kann nicht
allein aus beobachtungsdaten gewonnen
werden
ihm liegt stets und notwendig ein
kategorie ahles lebensform verständnis
zugrunde
auch den einsichten von schelling und
hegel gemäss liegt in jedem lebewesen
ein form verleihen der begriff der ihre
zweckmäßigkeit bestimmt als form des
denkens bringt der lebensform begriff
die vielgestaltigkeit der infizierungen
unter einer einheit und ermöglicht so
den menschen überhaupt erst das erkennen
und verstehen von lebewesen
von sidonia wir hatten auch schon darauf
hingewiesen
erst auf der basis des konzepts der
lebensformen können lebewesen als
ganzheit mit zugehörigen eigenschaften
fähigkeiten phasen und von zügen erfasst
werden
denn erst die lebensform vereint
zugleich die diversen eigenschaften und
fähigkeiten eines gegebenen lebewesens
sowie die verschiedenen phasen und volk
züge seines lebens prozesses
infolgedessen liegt der lebensform
begriff der klassifikation lebendiger
individuen notwendig zugrunde und wird
nicht erst etwa von ihren eigenschaften
und fähigkeiten abstrahiert
beziehungsweise induktiv hergeleitet im
rahmen der bestimmung empirisch
gehaltvoller lebensformen distanziert
thompson sich dann wieder von hegel für
den der begriff gegenüber der natur
stets prioritär und die natur gegenüber
dem begriff prinzipiell defizitär bleibt
auch wenn thompson selbst keinen bezug
zur natur philosophie schellings
herstellt scheint er sich meiner meinung
nach mit seiner darstellung der genese
von empirisch gehaltvollen lebensformen
beschreibungen durchaus einen schritt
auf schelling zuzubewegen so liegt die
von ihm deutlich hervorgehobene
wechselseitige abhängigkeit beziehung
zwischen deskriptive und normativen
beschreibungen geben der empirisch
gehabt gehaltvollen lebensform
zusammenfallen
zumindest er einen wirklichkeit
zusammenhang von lebewesen und
lebensformen im sinne schellings nah als
eine vorrangstellung des lebensformen
begriffs im sinne hegels werden die
begriffe leben lebensform und so weiter
für toms und logischer kategorien also
analytische begriffe apriori darstellen
die unmittelbar durch die vernunft
gegeben sind muss die empirisch
gehaltvolle lebensform als integratives
konzept aufgefasst werden dass reinen
lebensform begriff und empirisch
gegebene lebewesen miteinander
vermittelt auch im sinne des
aristotelischen eijlers sind stoff und
formen 2 in der lebensform vereinte
momente die empirisch gehaltvolle
lebensformen kann mit den worten
stekeler weithofer als auch trefflich
als material begrifflich generisches
wissen bezeichnet werden
in der empirisch gehaltvollen
lebensformen sind einzelheit und
allgemeinheit verschränkt da hier die
mannigfaltigen instanz ihr ungen der
exemplare unter die einheit des begriffs
gebracht werden nun vorhat thompson
leider auf der app ist ökologische nebel
und zieht die in seiner theorie
angelegten konsequenzen für eine ethik
der belebten natur nicht oder jedenfalls
nicht deutlich genug kam jetzt zu punkt
3 naturgemäß enorm
vith nicht thomaner lebensform
naturgemäße gut heilt zwar arbeitet
thompson heraus dass lebensformen einen
natural standard für ihre exemplare
enthalten deutet diesen allerdings
ausschließlich evaluation aktiv im sinne
einer naturgemäßen gutheil oder
mangelhaftigkeit von individuellen
lebewesen als exemplare einer
spezifischen lebensform dabei vom geht
die spezies abhängigkeit oder auch
lebensform relativität als sein
leitmotiv der die naturgeschichte einer
lebensform oder spezies definiere die
lebewesen einer bestimmten art leben bzw
leben sollen
ohne den verweis auf die lebensform und
ihre zugehörigen naturgeschichte gebe es
keine lebensbeschreibungen der union
keine tätigkeit eines individuums als
essen reproduktion usw identifiziert
werden können
daher seien naturhistorische urteile
immer auf den lebenszyklus eines
individuums und seiner entsprechenden
art bezogen
das systematische potenzial welches das
thomson konzept der beschreibung von
lebensformen mittels naturhistorische
urteile in ethisch normativer hinsicht
birgt geht es also noch auszuschöpfen
wipperfürth hat damit bereits begonnen
und widmet sich der näheren untersuchung
von normativen implikationen natur
historischer in der spezifischen
ausprägung natur teleologische urteile
sie weist darauf hin dass
naturhistorischen urteilen eine
teleologische struktur zu eigen ist die
auf etwas verwaist was im lebenszyklus
individueller lebewesen eine rolle
spielt madoffs card kommt später auf den
punkt dass es für das lebewesen selbst
eine rolle spielten beide teams erst
aber da werde ich jetzt heute nicht mehr
drauf eingehen
im rahmen ihres neo aristotelischen
naturalismus beschreibt und eine
spezifische art der evaluation
sie bezeichnet die logische form der
bewertung als natural bündnis ein defekt
in living things und der naturgemäß sehr
gut heilt und naturgemäß
mangelhaftigkeit versteht vor die gut
heilt oder mangelhaftigkeit eines
individuellen lebewesens bzw seiner
verfasstheit charakteristik oder
tätigkeiten in relation zu seiner
spezifischen lebensformen und greift die
idee des natural standard von thomson
auf und entwickelt sie unter der
bezeichnung normative die weiter in
diesem rahmen äußert sie sich
vereinzelt zwar auch über ein für
lebewesen gutes ihr hauptaugenmerk gilt
allerdings der bestimmung von lebewesen
als gute oder schlechte instanz ihr
ungen ihrer spezifischen lebensform
gemeinhin spreche man davon wie jedes
exemplar einer spezies sein müsse und
was es tun müsse um ein gutes exemplar
zu sein
die aristotelische notwendigkeiten
hängen von den bedürfnissen der
jeweiligen pflanzen respektive tierart
ab und bestimmen zusammen mit deren
natürlichen lebensraum und
verhaltensrepertoire was ist für
exemplare einer bestimmten spezies
bedeute so zu sein wie sie sein sollten
und das zu tun was sie tun sollten eine
gute löwen müsse etwa ihre jungen und
dann ihren jungen das jagen und erlegen
von beutetieren lehrern und eine biene
müsse den tanz der bienen beherrschen um
nicht als defektes exemplar zu gelten
bei der bestimmung der löwen und der
biene als gutes und ein mangelhaftes
exemplar ihrer art handle es sich um
objektive tatsachen als gelungen gelten
somit alles was den typischen
lebenszyklus einer spezies verwirkliche
wut schreibt zitat das gut der eiche ist
ihr individueller und reproduktiver
lebenszyklus was sie für diesen zyklus
braucht zählt in ihrem fall als eine
aristotelische notwendigkeit da sie sich
nicht wie ein schilfrohr wind bieten
kann ist die arche nur dann so wie sie
sein sollte wenn sie tiefe und kräftige
wurzeln hat zitat ende
ein merkmal das naturhistorische urteil
von statistischen urteilen über einige
die mehrheit oder alle exemplare eine
art ab grenze liege darin dass es auf
die theologie der lebensform bezogen sei
es zeige direkt oder indirekt an wie
leben funktioniere wie etwa essen
wachsen und verteidigung bei einer
bestimmten spezies in einem konkreten
habitat zustande kommen
aufgrund dessen könnte man mittels
naturhistorische urteile normen und
nicht bloß statistischen normalität in
ausdrücken
eine vergleiche eine vergleichbare
erklärung generischer urteile liefert
auch stekeler weithofer im schnitt
verhältnis zweier verschiedener urteile
eines naturhistorischen urteils und
eines urteils über einzelne lebewesen
sei die evaluierung des naturgemäß guten
eines individuell individuellen
lebewesens daher auch ohne verweis auf
menschliche interessen oder wünsche
möglich mein hauptaugenmerk liegt nun
auf dem für lebewesen guten das heißt
ihrem je eigenen gut im sinne eines
ihnen zuträglichen denn die naturgemäße
gut von individuellen lebewesen
ihr evaluationen normatives wohl
gebildet sein als exemplar ist nur eine
seite naturgemäß an normativität mit
blick auf implikationen für eine ethik
der belebten natur ist die andere von
thomson und vernachlässigte seite die
eigentlich entscheidende die andere
seite naturgemäß normativität kann also
als naturgemäße zuträglich kite
bezeichnet werden das wäre dann hier die
tabelle vor dem hintergrund des lebens
vom konzept und einer wohl verstandenen
theologie das heißt einer
zielgerichteten jedoch nicht notwendig
bewusstseins gesteuerten oder absicht
geleiteten zweckmäßigkeit eröffnet sich
ein ethisch normativer zugang zur
belebten natur denn naturhistorische
natur teleologische urteile weil sie ihn
unter dem gesichtspunkt naturgemäß eher
zuträglich kite auch darauf hin unter
welchen bedingungen ein exemplar einer
spezies gedeiht als exemplare einer
lebensform zeichnen sich alle lebewesen
durch eine für sie naturgemäße
zuträglich kite aus die auf ein für sie
ihr eigenes gut im sinne eines ihnen
zuträglichen verweis und erlaubt sie als
in besseren beziehungsweise schlechteren
zuständen befindlich zu beurteilen
naturhistorische natur teleologische
urteile verweisen also auf die
naturgemäße zuträglich kite für
individuelle lebewesen als exemplare
einer spezifischen lebensformen und
drücken aus dass etwas gut für sie ist
wie alle anderen formen naturhistorische
urteile auch werden sie im rahmen der
integrativen lebensform beschreibung
generiert die ideen für jede
auseinandersetzung mit lebewesen
konstitutiven lebensformen begriff mit
den mannigfaltigen daten und fakten
empirisch gegebener einzel lebewesen
vermittelt lebensform beschreibungen und
so auch die in ihnen enthaltenen urteile
naturgemäß gut haid und naturgemäß eher
zuträglich kite sind zugleich empirisch
gehaltvoll wie begrifflich
vorstrukturiert die lebensform bildet
den referenzrahmen für die beurteilung
von lebens prozessen als gedeihlich bzw
weise von zuständen von lebewesen als
besser oder schlechter
es ist nicht erforderlich dass ein
lebewesen auch nur prinzipiell dazu in
der lage sein muss interessen im sinne
bewusster präferenzen ausbilden zu
können damit urteile über seine
naturgemäße zuträglich kite gebildet und
handlungen an ihm als für sein eigenes
gut zu oder abträglich bewertet werden
können denn der zugehörigkeit eines
lebewesens zu einer bestimmten
lebensform kann auch ohne sein eigenes
wissen darum entnommen werden was wir so
einen theologisch verfassten lebens
prozess zu oder abträglich ist das
bewusste empfinden des eigenen wohl
stellt somit keine notwendige
voraussetzung für die bestimmung
naturgemäß eher zuträglich kite da viel
mehr ist selbst niederen tieren und
pflanzen ein eigenes von menschen
unabhängiges gut nach maßgabe ihrer
spezifischen lebensform zuzuschreiben
selbstbewusste bewusste und bewusstseins
lose das heißt alle lebewesen zeichnen
sich durch ihre fähigkeit zu gedeihen
aus alle verkörpern einen individuellen
standpunkt in der welt und allen kann
ein ereignis gut zugeschrieben werden
insofern wird vor dem hintergrund der in
der lebensform verankerten naturgemäßen
zuträglich kite die zustände aller
lebewesen unabhängig von menschlichen
interessen ethisch normativ beurteilbar
damit komme ich jetzt zu den
konsequenzen für eine ethik der belebten
natur da also auch handlungen an
niederen tieren und pflanzen als für
diese schädlich beurteilt werden können
ist allein aufgrund von konsistenz
bedingungen schon nicht einsichtig
weshalb schädigung von menschen und
höher entwickelten tieren einer
moralischen bewährt barkeit unterstehen
sollten jene von niederen tieren und
pflanzen hingegen nicht gedeihen
fähigkeit als schwellen kriterium für
eine lange zeit waren der anthropozän
tourismus und mit ihm die überzeugung
dass allein menschen um ihrer selbst
willen moralisch zu berücksichtigen sind
vorherrschend
seit einiger zeit ist die an prozent
rische von der partie zentrischen
sichtweise abgelöst worden
die mittlerweile zumindest hinter
streitbaren standard avanciert ist im
zentrum des pato centris muss steht an
ausweitung argument gemäß welchem das
kriterium eines genuin interesses an
leidens vermeidung bei menschen auf
leidens bzw empfindungsfähigkeit ihre
nicht nur meine lebewesen extrapoliert
wird autoren die ansätze dieser art
vertreten gehen davon aus dass nicht
empfindungsfähigkeit interessen
zugeschrieben werden können
als konsequenz ergibt sich dass ihnen
auch kein wohl oder wehe zugefügt werden
kann will feinberg ist etwa der ansicht
es sei nicht möglich interessen losen
wesen zu schaden
es unterscheide sich etwa das für
pflanzen gute nicht von
guten für große dinge man sage zwar dass
eine bestimmte art von anstrich gut oder
schlecht für die innenwände eines hauses
sei dies verpflichtet den menschen
jedoch nicht zu der auffassung von
wänden als entitäten die ein eigenes gut
oder ein wohl um ihrer selbst willen
besessen wie bloße dinge werden gemäß
dem motto centris muss auch niedere
tiere und pflanzen gänzlich von
moralischer berücksichtigungswürdigen
ausgeschlossen
treffen die zuvor ausgeführten thesen
zur naturgemäßen zuträglich kite jedoch
zu gilt das für das das für lebewesen
gute ihr gedeihen begünstigt die partie
zentrische sichtweise die das kriterium
der empfindung beziehungsweise
leidensfähigkeit als willen schwellen
kriterium für die zuschreibung
moralischer berücksichtigungswürdigen
begreift und somit alle nicht
bewusstseins fähigen lebewesen für
moralische relevant erachtet ist demnach
durch eine gemäßigte bio zentrische
argumentation figur zu ersetzen welche
die fähigkeit gedeihen zu können als
minimal anforderungen für die
zuschreibung basala moralischer
berücksichtigungswürdigen versteht
ich komme jetzt zum letzten punkt also
der letzten konsequenz sozusagen von
naturgemäß normativität das sind dann
bei mir asymmetrisch nicht wird sie
pokere anerkennungs verhältnisse die
individuellen installierung von
lebensformen lösen bei ihrer wahrnehmung
dem erkennen durch ein moralisches
objekt in diesem bereits eine normativ
konnotierte wahrnehmung ein anerkennen
aus dieser umstand wird nicht zuletzt
von der besonderen form des denkens
welche die kategorie der lebensform
darstellt her wie zuvor ausgeführt
umfasst die kategorie der lebensform
unter anderem den den aspekt
naturgewässer normativität und erlaubt
dem moralischen subjekt ethisch
normative urteile bezüglich der für
exemplare einer lebensform naturgemäßen
zuträglich kite zu bilden das erkennen
von lebewesen als exemplare einer
spezifischen lebensform mit einer
spezifischen naturgemäßen zuträglich
kite fordert eine moral apples
theologischer hinsicht bereits ein
anerkennen ihrer denn in praktischer
hinsicht sind aktuell vernunft und moral
fähige personen die über den
lebensformen begriff verfügen und somit
einen zugang zu der aus der lebensform
ableitbaren naturgemäßen zuträglich kite
haben
unter berücksichtigung der ethischen
prinzipien der universalisierung und
unparteilichkeit sowie aufgrund der für
ihre eigene lebensform typischen
existenz weise als moralische subjekte
dazu angehalten das jeden eigene gut von
lebewesen anzuerkennen das heißt sie
ihre moralischen status entsprechend zu
berücksichtigen
daher ist trotz der unumstößlichen
geltung des systemischen anthropozän
tourismus ein anthropozän tourismus in
normativer hinsicht als partikularismus
sowie parteiisch zurück zu weisen
dichtes these dass personen durch ihre
bloße gegenwart andere personen zu ihrer
anerkennung anerkennung nötigen sollen
nicht nur untermauert sondern radikal
erweitert werden
so gilt auch für nicht humane lebewesen
dass ihre bloße existenz jede über das
konzept der lebensform verfügen die
person dazu nötigt sie als wesen mit je
eigenem gut zu erkennen und auf der
basis der ethischen prinzipien der
universalisierung und unparteilichkeit
als moralisch berücksichtigungswürdigen
zu erkennen denn mit ethischen normen es
stets ein kategorischer verbindlichkeit
anspruch verknüpft deren abstrahierend
von interessengeleiteten erwägungen
verlangt bei moralische subjekte sich
vor allem dadurch auszeichnen von ihren
eigenen interessen abstrahieren und
absehen zu können
impliziert impliziert die moralische
anerkennung nicht humaner lebewesen dem
anspruch nach nicht nur die korrekte
identifikation eines lebewesens das
erkennen sondern eine seiner lebensform
adäquate moralische berücksichtigung das
anerkennen
traditionelle anerkennungs konzeptionen
unter anderem jene von kant fichte und
hegel aber auch moderne
auseinandersetzung mit anerkennung in
vertrags theoretischer oder diskurs
ethischer hinsicht bestimmen
anerkennungs verhältnisse ausschließlich
als wechselseitigen und egalitären
prozess zwischen personen
meines erachtens sind wechselseitigkeit
und gleichheit jedoch keine notwendigen
kriterien für moralische anerkennung
gewiss konstituieren personen den kern
moralische anerkennungs verhältnisse da
erst durch sie als moralische subjekte
ethische bestimmungen entstehen der
person status kommt allen menschen
unabhängig von ihren eigenschaften und
fähigkeiten zu
die menge aller personen untergliedert
sich allerdings in subjekte und objekte
der moral subjekte der moral weisen eine
aktualisiert
vernunft und moral fähigkeit auf nach
diesem verständnis sind alle aktuell
vernunft und moral fähigen personen
zugleich subjekte und objekte der moral
während alle aktuellen nicht vernunft
und moral fähigen personen
ausschließlich als objekte der moral zu
begreifen sind die menge der moralischen
subjekte ist somit nicht deckungsgleich
mit der menge aller menschen
vor diesem hintergrund kann eine theorie
moralische anerkennungs verhältnisse
entwickelt werden innerhalb derer einzig
aktuell vernunft und moral fähige
personen als subjekte moralische
anerkennung operieren als objekte
moralische anerkennung hingegen nicht
nur alle personen sondern auch alle
nicht human lebewesen grundsätzlich
berücksichtigt werden
aus der andersartigkeit der möglichen
objekte moralische anerkennung ergeben
sich drei verschiedene anerkennungs
relationen die hier in der tabelle
zusammengefasst habe erstens symmetrisch
reziproke zweiten symmetrisch nicht
reziproke und drittens asymmetrischen
nicht reziproke anerkennungs
verhältnisse symmetrie bedeutet hier
der moralische status von anerkennendem
subjekt und anerkanntem objekt ist
gleich dem anerkennenden und dem
anerkannten kommt der absolute
moralische status der menschenwürde zu
asymmetrie bedeutet hier der moral
status von anerkennendem subjekt und
anerkanntem objekt ist ungleich dem
anerkennenden kommt der absolute
moralischen status der menschenwürde zu
das anerkannte ist vom bloß weg baarer
moralischer berücksichtigungswürdigen
wird sie positiv bedeutet hier dass
anerkennungs weiters wird wechselseitig
realisiert nicht reziprozität bedeutet
dass anerkennungs verhältnis wird
einseitig realisiert demnach
unterscheiden sich moralische
anerkennungs verhältnisse mit blick auf
den substanziellen moralischen status
ihrer adressaten symmetrisch oder
asymmetrisch sowie bezüglich der
prozeduralen realisierung des
moralischen verhältnisses wird die
prozent oder nicht drin zieht
symmetrisch reziproke anerkennungs
verhältnisse bilden die traditionelle
konzeption moralische anerkennungs
verhältnisse ab für die zwischen zwei
oder mehreren aktuell vernunft und moral
fähigen personen prinzipiell immer ein
gleichrangiges und wechselseitiges
anerkennungs verhältnis besteht eine
reduktion des moralischen raums auf
zwischenmenschliche beziehung
sich durch ein richtiges verhältnis
auszeichnen wird der verantwortung die
vernunft und moral fähige personen
gegenüber nicht von uns moral segen
personen haben jedoch nicht gerecht da
der moralischen status aller personen
gleich aller menschen als person gleich
ist ist auch ihr verhältnis auf der
abstraktionsebene ihres moralischen
status gleichrangig das heißt sie
militärisch hier in gründet die
möglichkeit eines symmetrischen jedoch
einseitigen anerkennungs verhältnissen
verhältnisses von eben dieser art sind
auch solche verhältnisse die
hinsichtlich der sozialen rolle
asymmetrisch hinsichtlich des person
status jedoch symmetrisch sind wie zb
anerkennungs verhältnisse zwischen
eltern und kleinkindern ärzten komatösen
patienten betreuen und menschen mit
schwerer geistiger behinderung da alle
genannten oder allen genannten der
absolute moralischen status der
menschenwürde in gleichem maße zukommt
sind anerkennungs verhältnisse zwischen
ihnen symmetrisch und gebührt allen
dieselbe moralische anerkennung
bezüglich der realisierung moralische
anerkennung bestehen jedoch auch
innerhalb der menge aller personen
gravierende unterschiede
schließlich zeichnen sich aktuell
vernunft und moral fähige personen
insbesondere durch ihre pflichten
aktuellen nicht verdunsten moral fähige
personen hingegen gerade durch ihre
rechte und schutz ansprüche aus ersteren
obliegt es ihre pflichten aktiv
auszuüben letztere beanspruchen ihre
rechte bloß passiv quartiere personen
seien folglich sind anerkennungs
verhältnisse zwischen aktuell vernunft
moral fähigen und aktuellen nicht von
uns die moral fähigen personen
symmetrisch nicht reziprok da die
realisierung moralische anerkennung
ausschließlich von seiten der aktuell
vernunft und moral fähigen personen
erfolgt unter der voraussetzung dass
moralische subjekte ihre ethische
urteilsbildung über personal und
unparteilich ausrichten wird nun ferner
dass die erkenntnis dass lebewesen an
ihr eigenes gut zugeschrieben werden
kann
hinreichend für die anerkenntnis ihres
moralischen status ist allerdings bleibt
das anerkennung verhelfen personen und
nicht um ein lebewesen grundsätzlich
nicht reziprok und asymmetrisch der
letztere video weder moralisch
verpflichtet sind noch moralisch absolut
verpflichten obwohl für nicht um eine
lebewesen als exemplare einer lebensform
naturgemäße zuträglich kite bestimmt und
ihnen ein moralisch relevanter
standpunkt zugeordnet werden
sie besitzen ein eigenes gut und
befinden sich in für aktuell vernunft
und moral fähige personen beurteilbar
besseren oder schlechteren zuständen ist
ihr moralischer status nicht mit jenem
von personen identisch auf der basis der
skala natur eröffnet sich vielmehr ein
hierarchie stabio centris muss in dessen
rahmen graduelle abstufungen
hinsichtlich des moralischen status von
lebewesen vorgenommen werden und den
exemplaren verschiedener lebensformen
verschiedene grade moralischer
berücksichtigungswürdigen zugeschrieben
werden können
die abstufungen des normativen status
reichen von absoluter moralischer
berücksichtigungswürdigen die
prinzipiell vernunft und moral fähigen
wesen zukommt bis hin zu weg baarer
moralischer berücksichtigungswürdigen
die alle nicht tomaten lebewesen
zugeschrieben werden muss mit der
auszeichnung nicht zu meiner lebewesen
als entitäten mit einem je eigenen gut
ergibt sich für die vernünftige person
somit eine moralische
berücksichtigungswürdigen aller nicht um
ein lebewesen die es im rahmen
asymmetrisch nicht reziproker
anerkennungs verhältnisse gerecht zu
werden gilt vielen dank